Now I'd like to introduce today's speaker,
Pamela Matson.
Professor Matson is Dean of
the Standford School of Earth, Energy, and
Environmental Sciences,
as well as an internationally recognized
interdisciplinary earth scientist,
academic leader, and
organizational strategist.
Her research focuses on the consequences
of agricultural intensification,
land-use change, and
nitrogen deposition for ecosystem and
the atmosphere, and on sustainable
development issues in developing regions.
Working mostly in the tropics, she and
her colleagues have identified the
negative consequences of deforestation and
intensive agriculture for the global and
local atmosphere, freshwater, and
marine systems and are working to develop
new approaches that reduced those impacts
while maintaining human livelihood and
well being.
She also works on the vulnerability of
food and water systems to climate change.
And with that,
I'd like to turn it over to Pam.
Welcome.
>> Welcome.
Thank you very much for being here.
I'm glad to have a chance to
talk with you this morning.
I'd like to talk about a framework and
an approach for pursuing sustainability,
and what I'm going to do is start
with a little bit about motivation,
why would we be doing this,
why do we care?
And then provide a framework for
analysis and decision making,
a framework that really anyone,
any leader could use.
I'll talk a little bit on why this is
really hard and then add a bit about
the tools that we can use to help make
good decisions for sustainability.
So first of all,
let me start with the question.
There we go.
Let me address the question,
what does sustainability mean?
Of course this is the term that's
used by many different people in
many different situations and
have different meanings.
But there are a couple that
matter to us in this context.
It really emerged initially
from the UN and from an ongoing
discussion about how to help the poorest
countries in the world develop.
And in develop, well,
socially and economically.
Going back to
the Brundtland Report in 1989,
our common future basically said, look if
we're going to meet the needs of people,
we're going to be working on
that very hard right now.
How do we do that and still not
forego opportunities for the future,
not compromise the future ability
of people to meet their own needs?
And this has been worked down very,
very hard over many decades.
Today, we have a new set of sustainable
development goals that the UN put
together last year through an engaged
stakeholder set of discussions.
And people, and organizations, and
institutions around the world
are working for those goals.
So that's sustainable development.
But now,
what about corporate sustainability?
This is another major emphasis
that has engaged lots
of corporations around the world
over the last couple of decades.
We think about the three legged stool, and
the triple bottom line, or the three E's
to represent the fact that corporations
are now trying to make decisions that make
sense economically in terms of profit,
but also socially, and environmentally.
And in many ways, this is now
relevant to the EFC value system
that many corporations
are placing on their operations.
So why do businesses engage in this?
Lots of reasons,
a lot of reasons having to do with
internal business sustainability,
with the well-being of the company
in both the short and the long term.
Lots of companies have engaged for
efficiency savings,
it saves a lot of money by using
resources more efficiently.
Many are identifying growth
opportunities in new markets that
are related to using scarce resources more
effectively for humans and human needs.
There are reputation issues.
There's certainly one way to attract,
recruit, and retain motivated
employees who care about the world, and
lots of elements of risk management.
But I think increasingly
corporations are buying into this,
they are engaging in this
because they are concerned.
They and their leaders are concerned about
the well-being of people beyond their own
corporation.
So it's about well-being
then in both cases.
So I think we can,
in a sense define sustainability
with a goal of well-being
of people today and
in the future of companies in this
next quarter, but in the longer term.
And of institutions,
and organizations, and people here,
but also all around the world.
That's the definition we're using for
sustainability's goal.
So we're talking about then well-being and
then we can ask a question,
what does well-being mean?
And there's been an international
conversation about this.
What are the constituents of well-being?
And absolutely at the top of
the list are material needs.
How do we meet the energy, and
food, and water, and shelter, and
material needs of people
all around the world?
But there's also well-being associated
with access to health care,
with access to education,
with access to economic opportunities.
And to the opportunities to live well and
to make profits,
and security, freedom of want and
fear, and so on.
These are all on the list.
And when we make a list like that,
we can then ask how well
are we doing in that list?
How well have we succeeded so
far in meeting the needs of people?
And there's a lot of
progress that's been made.
We know, for example,
that more people have access to more
kilocalories today than ever before.
So we're eating better.
More people have access to
healthcare than ever before.
So infant mortality rates are in decline,
the death of children under the age
of five, death rates have declined.
The death rates of women in child birth
have declined, lots of indicators there.
And in terms of education,
the literacy rates have just skyrocketed.
Most children today can read.
So lots of progress, and
maybe the best indicator for
that is to look at life
expectancies at first.
And when we think about that,
look at the graph here,
it shows life expectancy has
changed from 1950 to 2010.
In the developed countries of the world,
we're now living 80 years or
longer on average.
But in every country around the world has
seen some increase in life expectancy,
so that's a very good signal.
But you can also see in this graph the
real problem, and that is a huge disparity
between people living in the wealthiest
countries of the world and
people living in the very
poor parts of the world.
And that disparity shows up in
a number of different areas.
We have today a billion
people who can't read.
They're mostly adult women.
We have a billion without adequate
shelter or access to safe water,
or to sanitation, or
modern forms of energy.
Almost a billion people go to
bed hungry a lot of times.
And that's today, so
a huge challenge there.
But the planet is still growing,
our population is still growing.
So let's take a quick look at that
to get a sense for the issue.
So homo sapiens have been on the planet
for a couple hundred thousand years.
But just over the last 7, or 8,
9,000 years we've gotten to grow.
And it's because of at first,
because of settled agriculture,
because of the domestication of animals,
because people were living in settlements.
And so
by the time of Christ we had something
like 300 million people on the planet.
We had grown, we continue to
grow very slowly with more and
more people living in areas and run into
some problems like the Black Plague.
But in the 1800 everything changed.
Our population growth absolutely
took off incredibly quickly,
and in fact, we are still growing.
But we're not growing
exponentially anymore.
We are quite clearly going to
level off at a global population
level of 11 billion people or so.
Probably towards the end of this
century or the early part of the next.
That's a lot more people on
the planet that we don't have today,
whose needs are going to have to be met.
Whose well-being is a concern for
all of us.
Now that population is not distributed
evenly all around the planet,
and the growth and
change in it is not distributed evenly.
So, in this figure you can see
the red line towards the bottom
is the population in the developed
countries of the world.
You can see they've leveled off,
they're not growing.
The green line shows
the population changes in the less
developed countries of the world, like in
this case China, and India, and Indonesia.
Growing very rapidly at first,
now within a decade, or two, or
three of leveling off.
And then in the bottom purple line
you see the continued increase in
population growth in, what are the very
least developed areas of the world.
The countries of Sub-Saharan Africa for
example.
So we can look at that, and
see where the changes are occurring,
and where people will need
the most new resources, and
will need to work for well-being.
The other point about this slide is that,
or
not in the slide actually is that lot of
these people are living in cities now,
more than 50% today, probably more than
70% to 80% by the end of the century.
And even as population is slowing down and
stopping,
population growth is stopping, consumption
is continuing, it's increasing.
And that is good because many people right
now don't have access to enough things
in the world.
And, many people around the world
are moving into the middle class.
Though consumption will increase as well.
So you look at those trends, and
I hope you have seen huge opportunities
in this, but also huge challenges.
How are we going to meet
the needs of that growing, and
more consuming human population?
How are we going to do it in a way
that can be sustained over decades and
centuries?
And what does this mean for
all of the businesses in which we work?
How do we work towards into generation
of well-being given the situation.
So, I'm going to show you right now
a framework that was developed and
published in this book called
Pursuing Sustainability.
It's just a primer, and this framework
was intended for any leader.
Not just business leaders,
as the way of thinking about
the pursuit of sustainability.
At the top of the framework
we think about our goal,
the goal of intergenerational well-being.
And well-being of people, here and
around the world today and in the future.
So how do we meet that goal.
Well through a whole
bunch of production and
consumption activities
that we're all engaged in.
We're creating the goods and
services and trying to provide them for
people to consume.
We are the actors and agents doing that.
And there's lots and lots of ways
that we can do those things better or
worse that will have an impact on long
term intergenerational well-being.
We could spend hours talking
through these things,
but what we're going to do
right now is move down to
the underlying assets that control
what we can produce and consume.
We’re going to talk about five
capital assets that ultimately
determine human well-being.
So, let’s start at the top,
Natural Capital, this is an asset,
these are the people of the world,
people from different places,
it’s the numbers of people,
their demographics, their health status,
their level of education and knowledge
accumulation, all of the things that
allow people, individual people,
to be actors and decision makers.
We have Social Capital.
Those are our rules and
regulations, the norms and
institutions, the networks that we use.
The strategies including financing
strategies that allow us to move and
make decisions for sustainability.
Over on the other side of the graph
we have Manufactured Capital.
This is everything we build,
everything we make.
It's our buildings, our factories,
the stuff we make inside of the factories,
the new technology and
tools, it's our roads, and
our airports, and
everything else that the humans make.
Over on the right we
have Knowledge Capital.
This is the kind of new knowledge
that's created in places like
Stanford University, other universities,
research centers of companies and
of governments.
And it's also the knowledge that is
a pain through practice in experience
in the field or in the factory.
Crucial to have that knowledge as we move
ahead in a transition to sustainability.
And then finally at the bottom,
is Natural Capital.
This is basically our life support system.
It's all of the resources that we call on,
in order to power that manufactured
capital and to meet the needs of people.
It's the place,
it's the environment in which we live,
our atmosphere, our climate system.
And the species and the ecosystems on
land and in the ocean, as it provides so
many of the things that we need.
So that's natural capital.
Those five capital assets underlie our
ability to meet our goal of well-being.
And the bottom line is if they go down,
if we lose them, or if they're declining.
Then we're in trouble,
if our goal is to worry about
the future as well as right now.
So, I would in a normal kind
of classroom environment,
I'd ask you right now,
which of these capitals.
Capital assets do you think is under
most stress, which ones are declining.
And some of you would say social capital.
You would say without the rule of law,
we can't make any progress.
And you'd be right.
Others might say it's manufacture capital.
We don't have the right infrastructure to
allow these new technologies to take off,
and you'd be right there too.
But if you're thinking globally,
the answer is natural capital.
Globally, there is no doubt that
our whole range of natural
capital assets are in decline.
And it's not hard to see why.
If you go back to this
population growth graph.
And you look at that dramatic increase.
In 1800, we had 1 billion people.
By 1924, we had 2 billion people.
By the 1950, we had 3 billion people.
Now, we have 7.4 billion and
we're going to 11.
If you look at that graph and
how quickly that happened,
you can kind of understand why our life
support system had been in distress.
I mean, we've been in a mad dash
to meet the need of people and
we've done that pretty well.
We've met need for
energy by using biomass and
most especially fossil fuels,
coal, oil and gas.
We've met the needs of people for
food through some
wonderful new technologies that increased
yields, also through virgin lands,
natural lands, agriculture and
we kept food pace, the food production
had pace with human population growth.
We've met the needs of people for water
for a whole range in different uses by
building reservoirs, by pumping aqua
first, by using water in rivers and
we've succeeded in all of these things and
many more.
However, many of those efforts have had
unintended negative consequences and
simply we didn't take time to worry
about the impact on natural capital.
So burning of fossil fuels, absolutely
crucial for meeting energy needs and
yet is leading to very high emissions
of air pollutants and greenhouse gases.
Likewise, greenhouse gases,
methane, nitrous oxide,
carbon dioxide coming from agriculture and
those together add up to a global
change in temperature that
we're seeing right now.
There's absolutely no doubt of that and
that temperature change is
having a range of impacts.
Things like very heavy precipitation
events and flooding or
extended droughts, or sea level rise,
or increased storminess.
That ultimately affect our ability
to meet the needs of people.
So, the affect are sustainability goals
and climate isn't the only thing.
There's a whole, long list of ways that
our natural capital is being degraded.
And again, we could spend a lot
of time focusing on the different
items in this list, but
I'm going to move on to say,
the real challenge here is to
change that downward arrow for
natural capital to an upward arrow while
still meeting the needs of people,
while still paid attention to
the well-being of our people in
organizations today as well as in
the future and I think we can do that.
There are fantastic examples right now
of companies engaging in doing exactly
that and
we'll come back to that in a minute.
I want to tell you a quick story about how
our efforts to meet the needs of people
have had unintended consequences and
then we'll go to some stories of where
things are going in the right direction.
So green revolution, the green revolution
took place in the 1950s through the 1990s.
Really, launched by a group of academic
scientists as well as nongovernmental
organizations who recognized that human
population was growing very quickly and
there was no way we could meet the food
needs of those people without changing
the way we do things.
So they created, they invested in
creating a number of new technologies.
Improved genetic materials
of their cereal crops.
New ways to carry out irrigation,
new kinds of industrial fertilizers,
new pesticides, new mechanization.
And as you would recognize, a lot of those
new technologies launched companies or
rather companies launch
those new technologies.
Huge advancement there.
Of course, the new technologies themselves
are weren't going to be enough.
The people in the field have to know how
to use them, so both the companies and
the nongovernmental organizations
began to invest in human capital.
Training farmers in making sure that
they have the education needed in order
to employ those technologies and that
whole system yielded a fantastic result.
We were able to keep food production
at pace with that very rapid
human population growth.
Rally wonderful, but one problem
was that nobody was really paying
a whole lot of attention to
the draw down in natural capital.
The soil resources, the effect
of fertilizers on water systems,
the use of water for irrigation and
over pumping of aquifers.
Air pollution problems,
green house gas emissions and on and on.
Again, changes that affect our ability
to meet the needs of people for
food in the future.
So, that went down.
There was also a bit of a drop
in social and natural capital in
some places as whole communities,
especially indigenous groups, lost out.
Lost their land and
lost their ability to play.
Well, since then, all of our efforts
within the last couple of decades have
been trying to reimburse that.
How can we do this differently?
How can we still grow enough food,
engage enough companies and
engage enough individuals to
meet the needs of people, but
without those negative unintended
consequences and there are great stories.
I'm going to just share one story and
that is the story of the sustainable
harvest coffee importers,
because I think it illustrates paying
attention to all of these assets.
So David Griswold, the founder
in the 1980s soon after college,
I guess volunteered by working with
poor coffee farmers in Mexico and
he began to see how
difficult their lives were.
How challenging it was despite
all their hard work for
their well-being to increase and
he decided later to create a business that
would help them improve their wellbeing,
but would also be profitable.
So, what did he worry about?
He worried about finding
that knowledge capital and
creating that new knowledge that they
could employ in technologies in the field,
their manufacture capital that would
allow farmers to get more value for
the crops that they were growing.
That would allow them to reduce
the cost of fertilizers and
add more of the resources they had at
hand including organic fertilizers.
That would reduce the environmental
consequences of what they do.
He recognized again,
that you can have new technology that
people need to know how to use it.
Farmers were engaged,
were involved in learning and training and
using and improving those technologies.
So he worked with the capital asset
of human capital and he made sure and
his teams made sure that the natural
capital wasn't declining and
actually was improving,
because of these processes.
He also focused on supply chain
dynamics and increased the transparency
of the supply chain, so that those
poor farmers actually understood where
their coffee was going and who was
making money on it and built a trust in
a long term consistency in the supply
chain that pays that back over time.
Ultimately, producing a lot of coffee.
Increasing the well-being of the people
there and creating a profitable company.
The story is not over and
it could go on and on,
but it gives you an idea of
what one corporation can do.
So I think all the challenge for
all of us is to think about how
me manage all of these assets and
their interactions in ways that
promote intergenerational well-being.
And again,
what I would do in classroom situation,
if you were all sitting
here with us today,
is ask you to apply the framework to your
challenge, to your business challenge.
In a way,
it's a way of thinking about the problem.
It's a checklist to remind us not
to forget really important assets
as we make our plans.
But you can take that home and
do it later.
So I have to be truthful in saying,
this is not as easy as it sounds.
This is a really hard problem.
And it's because these systems are very,
very complex.
They are not simple, linear relationships
among the different components of them.
So just briefly,
let me say what a system is.
So we talked about complex systems.
A system, as defined by a huge field
of inquiry, of systems thinking,
systems dynamics, systems engineering,
systems analysis,
systems ecology, are all focused on
understanding these complex systems of
interconnected elements that are organized
in a way that achieves something.
So the boat in the picture is a system,
but
the lake and the shoreline and the rescue
organizations that the boat is surrounded
by could also be considered the system.
Likewise, your factory is a system,
but your business contains supply
chain and other elements that
are probably a better way to think
about your business as a system.
And for sustainability,
we have to broaden these boundaries.
So that we include the environment and
the well-being of people as well.
Okay, but systems dynamics has
focused a lot on the challenges
of understanding and
managing complex systems.
And there's a whole list of
characteristics that make a system,
whether it's your business system or
anything else difficult.
And I'm going to pick out just a couple of
these to illustrate a way of thinking and
a way of analyzing our decisions and
interventions.
So that we are trying to assure that
they're not resulting in negative,
unintended consequences.
So let me start with positive and
negative feedbacks.
I'm going to just jump into
an example here to illustrate this.
This is a positive feedback cycle that
plays out in many different areas and many
different organizations would approach
sustainability of water use in this way.
So we have an effort going
on at conservation of water.
Why are we doing this?
Because this community realized that
it was using too much water and
their water resources were going down.
And they were worried about where they
were going to get it in the future.
So they started to invest in
conservation of water, and
they saw great results,
great water efficiency results.
That led to a recognition and
an awareness of the positive
results which then continued to
encourage public support for
that water conservation,
which then led to more conservation.
So that's the positive feedback cycle.
That's sometimes called a virtuous cycle,
sometimes called a reinforcing
feedback process.
And over on the right, what resulted was
that because of the water efficiency
results, they took less
total water from the rivers.
And they had more stream flows that
they could count on for the long term.
So that's the great success story there,
seemed to work.
But one problem for
them is that their boundary around
their system wasn't quite wide enough.
What happens in the situation is that
because there was less total water
being taken from the rivers,
there was more available water for
new business and
new homes to come in and they came in.
They came into the region, and
that increased total water demand.
And that increased the amount
of water taken from rivers and
led to lower stream flows.
So that was a negative feedback,
a balancing feedback cycle
that unfortunately led to that
original effort to increase
sustainability of water
use to be not successful.
These kinds of things happen everywhere.
Another quick example of that,
this an example,
say that we're in a community where
they're a very underprivileged community.
Where a lot of people don't have
access to services, and to schools,
and playgrounds, and
hospitals, and so forth.
The leaders in this area, the government,
the non-governmental organizations, and
corporations decided to invest in
improving infrastructure and services.
That led to an increase in the well-being
of the community residents,
so exactly what they wanted to do.
And that led to more support,
a success story, and
it continued government, NGO,
and corporate investment.
Another positive feedback cycle,
another reinforcing one,
another virtuous cycle.
But when others outside that region,
who were still underprivileged,
found out about it, they saw the signs of
well-being and they moved to the region so
that they could have access to
that infrastructure and services.
And what happened then is that once again,
that community did not have enough
infrastructure and
services to meet the needs of the people.
So the positive feedback was pushed
back by the negative feedback.
These kinds of feedback cycles
happen everywhere, and they're so
common that they fall into an archetype
that's called fixes that fail.
You have a problem, you put a fix in
place, you solve the problem for a while,
but then you get unintended consequences.
And part of the problem is
the scale at you you're looking,
the boundaries that you have around
your system of are too small.
And there are a lot of
these kinds of feedback
cycles that happen over and
over again in municipalities,
in communities of all kinds, in companies,
in all kinds of organizations.
The good thing about it is they happen so
often that there's a list of them now.
There's ten different archetypes for
these feedbacks that will get in the way
of efforts to shift towards
a sustainability goal.
And you can manage for
those kinds of feedback situations,
if you're aware of them.
This is an area that we could
go into a lot more deeply,
but I want to move on very quickly
to a couple of other issues.
Another challenge that we run into as
we're trying to manage these complex
systems for sustainability is that
there's all kinds of connections that
takes place across space and time,
and there's a lot of invisibilities.
There's a lot of situations where what I
do as a citizen is having impacts far,
far away and I don't even realize it,
so invisibility.
So we sometimes get in trouble
because of that, when cause and
effect are distant in time or in space,
and when solutions require actions
at number of different scales.
Let me give you a quick example
of this fascinating example, but
has some solutions embedded now.
And that is an example around palm oil.
So I'm drawing here on work
by one of my colleagues here,
Jim Leape, at Woods Institute for
the Environment.
So palm oil is an ingredient in half
of the products in the grocery store.
We all use it all the time in many
different kinds of purchases that we make.
If you go through the long supply chain
you can ask the question where
does that palm oil originate from?
What is needed at the base of
the supply chain for that?
And the answer is, it comes from palm
oil plants from palm plantation.
50% of the palm plantations in
the world around that are in Indonesia.
There's maybe another third in Malaysia,
or
at least the palm oil is coming
from Malaysian plantations.
And palm oil plantations are also
expanding now into parts of
Central and Eastern Africa and
Latin America.
So that's fine.
That's an agricultural crop that is needed
but there are a couple problems with it.
And one is that most of the palm
plantations were originally and
quite recently tropical forests
often with very heavy peak soils
that have a lot of carbon in it and
as the forests are burned to be
converted into plantation,
they emit huge amounts of air pollutants.
And so you see pictures,
I'm sure you've seen pictures of people
living in downwind cities with masks on
because they're suffering from air
pollution from the biomass burning.
But they also emit a lot
of greenhouse gases.
And then of concern to many communities is
that they are a threat to biodiversity.
There's a threat of extinction.
This is a graphic from the World
Wildlife Fund focusing on a species
that is under huge stress because of
deforestation related to palm oil.
So the question that is,
what do we do about that?
How do we meet the needs for palm oil
without those negative consequences?
That question was addressed; it has been
a big problem that has been approached.
Very slowly over time, but it's growing
right now in terms of the action.
So going back to 2001,
a small Swiss retailer,
[INAUDIBLE] got together with a couple
of conservation organizations,
non-government organizations and
then they brought stakeholders together
to create a certification system.
They developed a round table on palm oil,
and they created together
a set of standards that would allow for
palm oil to be certified sustainable.
So that was an important first step,
seemed to make sense.
The next step was that they then and
other NGOs came in at this point
tried to engage some of the biggest
corporations in the world who sourced
palm oil from palm plantations.
And the first one to be brought in was
Unilever, and not surprisingly Unilever
has a long record of social
responsibility, and they agreed
that they wanted to use certified palm
oil and not have deforestation occurring.
And then over time many, many,
other players have come in,
there's a true partnership among these
corporations as they seek to source
palm oil from systems where
deforestation was not a factor.
So that story goes on too, but
it's a nice example of how partnership
can come together to work
towards sustainability.
I'm going to move on passed
this next characteristic,
although it's a fascinating one and
wrap this up.
So we have a lot of complexity out
there as we are trying to work
towards long-term
intergenerational human wellbeing.
And it would be nice if we could say
there's one great set of models or
simulation models or whatever.
That all you have to do is put
in an intervention and the model
will tell you whether you're going to have
unintended negative consequences or not.
The model will tell you if it's
a smart move to make or not.
Unfortunately, no such
integrated systems model exists.
And if there were, we probably
wouldn't believe it, too complex.
But there are lots of
tool that we can use.
This is a list of some of them.
Many of these are use right now by
corporations that are trying to make sure
that they have sustainable supply chain
and many more could be used in the future.
In our discussions and courses here we
can dive into these with some detail and
give examples of how these different tools
are actually used to help decision makers
make good decisions for sustainability.
But the bottom line is,
we're going to need a lot of humility.
We're trying to do something that is new,
we're going to get some things wrong.
We need to be able to
monitor how well we're doing,
to learn from our mistakes as well as
our successes, and to adapt as we go.
So with that I want to just end by saying
that we in our program here at Stanford,
and believe that there are three really
important characteristics of leaders for
sustainability, leaders in businesses,
NGOs, academic institutions, governments.
First of all the ability to
understand these complex systems
which we've just been talking about.
And to make decisions recognizing
those five capital assets.
The second is the mindset and the capacity
to lead in this very dynamic world.
And Julia Novy-Hildesley,
a Professor of Practice here,
will be speaking on this topic
later in May, at a webinar.
And finally, the ability to design
innovations that can scale,
that can lead to change
at a scale that matters.
And Professor of Practice, Banny Banerjee,
we'll be getting a webinar on
that topic also later in May.
So with that,
I thank you very much for listening,
for being part of this discussion,
and I look forward to your questions.
Thank you.
>> Well, thank you very much, Pamela.
This was a fascinating conversation.
And so, with that I'm going to turn it
back over to Pam with a few questions
that have come up.
And so, Pam, the first question I
would like to ask you is we talked
about all these very complex
systems of all these activities.
Which industry do you think is
the most meaningful to intervene in,
is it most relevant to, the public sector,
the private sector etc.,
what are your thoughts on that?
>> I think I have to say all of the above.
I think there is a role for everyone when
I teach these courses at Stanford to
the up and coming leaders in the future.
I'm basically saying it doesn't matter
where you're going in your life,
you have an important role to play in
this and whether you're going into
non-profits or government or
corporations of all kinds, it matters.
I think, as we look at some
of the big challenges today,
meeting the energy needs of people,
meeting the food needs of people are huge.
And all of the industries and
corporations and
companies engaged in doing those
things have a role to play.
I think ultimately that example that I've
showed of the Palm Oil Certification
program, it's maybe the way of the future,
I think more and more.
Corporations and industries are going to
be working together to try to find even
level playing fields in
which they can do good for
themselves as well as do good for
the world.
There's no doubt that we're going to need
a lot more food, energy, water resources.
And we're going to have to find
ways to provide them, much,
much more efficiently in order
to sustain for the long term.
>> Thank you.
So another thread of questions
that I'm seeing come up is around
the different types of intervention,
or education or
activity may be needed in first world
countries or more affluent societies.
And maybe third world or
less affluent societies.
How are, how are the needs in this two
area different I'm sure both need some
kind of intervention and, and education.
>> Right, well it's an interesting
question because I think,
obviously, in the third world countries,
well, let me start.
In the most developed
countries of the world,
we still have lots of
sustainability challenges.
We have an opportunity to use our
resources, to meet the needs of people,
to focus on human wellbeing in much
better ways than we are today.
So it's not like we've got it figured out.
But I think what's really interesting is
to see the leap frogging in the third
world, in the developing
countries of the world.
Where companies and
corporations are moving in to help
the citizens of those countries,
those nations.
Meet their needs through better
healthcare, through more food,
through better water resources
in ways that are conservative.
In ways that are smart from
a sustainability perspective,
that are efficient but
still meet the people's needs.
And I think companies that are engaging
right now in the developing world,
in some of the poorest parts
of the developing world,
are among the most innovative.
Because they have an opportunity
to innovate new approaches that
actually make sense.
Both for those people right there and
for the environment and for
the abilities for future generations
to have their needs met.
So very exciting and I think that's
the part that excites me most.
>> So we've talked about the fact that
companies typically measure their success
in economic terms.
And early on in the webinar we talked
about the three legs of that stool.
What are some examples you can give to
ways companies have successfully used,
what measures have they used to tap
into these other components beyond
the economic value?
>> Yeah, I mean, I think there's some
really wonderful case studies out there.
I think,
if you take a look at Unilever's 2020
sustainable living program,
there's a wonderful list of
ways at every scale in that
corporation they're engaging.
From the product design stage,
where they're thinking very
carefully about reducing plastics,
for example, or
creating new products that require less,
new detergents that
require less use of water.
Those kinds of innovations
that then will go out and
be actually making a big difference
to people all around the world.
But then you have on the other hand,
companies that are trying very hard
to manage their supply chains so
that each part of the supply chain
is actually using best practice.
And that's incredibly challenging.
That's where certification programs and
standards become very, very helpful.
But they're using life
cycle assessment and
other approaches to try to make sure
that at every stage in the supply chain.
They're doing the best they can.
I think that, really,
sustainability is something that has
to engage every part of a company.
It can't just be the CEO saying
we should be doing this.
It has to be the CEO and the C suite
on down, committed to making it happen.
But giving opportunities to everybody
in the company to use their
own innovation skills to find solutions.
And many, many companies, I think,
have done that with respect to
how they use their own resources.
They reduce their energy,
they reduce water, they reduce waste and
they've succeeded.
They've made money just because of that.
That's fantastic, but increasingly,
companies are taking that perspective
outside of the walls of
their own factories.
>> Mm-hm, all right, so you talked a lot
about the complexity of the system and
how there are so many different components
to each activity that we want to do.
Who is ultimately accountable for
that in the sense of,
since there's so many actors.
>> Yeah, well, I think you have to
put a boundary around your system and
try to do your best within it.
Ultimately, nobody is in control.
We're talking about a global
highly interconnected system.
And so a lot of this is bottom-up.
A lot of it is recognizing that
future well-being of one's community,
one's company,
one's governmental organization or
non-governmental organization, depends on
everybody doing the best thing they can.
That's one of the reasons,
I think, the coalitions,
the partnerships,
that are being developed are so exciting,
because there is no government for
the globe saying you must do this.
It has to come from the bottom up.
That said, the UN's sustainable
development goals that I mentioned at
the very beginning provide an impetus for
that.
They've identified really hugely
important areas that need to be
solved in the developing world.
And for
companies to think about those goals, and
to recognize that these
are opportunities for
them to play in an emerging market,
if you will.
But to also help solve those problems,
that's the exciting combination.
>> Yeah, that's really wonderful.
So I think there are a lot of people on
the line today that are realizing that
this is a very, very important topic.
And would like to do more to convince
potentially some others within
the organizer how important this is.
What are some hooks or
some strategies that you would use
to help them make that argument?
>> Yeah, very good question.
And that's probably one that
the next two speakers in our series
will be able to address
much better than I,
because they're more focused on
business settings than I have been.
But that said, we used to think
about training people to be
the sustainability director or
the environment director in
an organization, and
that's still very, very important.
Those people play very,
very important roles.
But we also want the top
leaders to get it.
And one of the big challenges
is how to engage them.
That's one of the reasons that we're
launching this executive education
program, because from the very top,
we want people to understand
both the challenge and
the opportunity for their company.
I think the companies that have
engaged probably most effectively
have had both leaders at the bottom and
at the top who've worked together.
And they've empowered their
employees to be innovative and
to engage at every stage,
at every part of the organization, so
it becomes an organization wide effort.
And I think the payoff is pretty great for
those.
Both in terms of maintaining,
retaining great employees, but
also in terms of their own profitability
and social responsibility.
>> Yeah, and I think one thing that might
be embedded in what you said, which we can
call it more explicitly, is really
talking about both the challenges and
the opportunities when you
hear of all these different,
the growing population and
the growth in consumption.
It's very easy to think about the
challenges and be a little demoralized,
but I think there's also a lot of
opportunity that could be called out
as a result of that.
>> Absolutely, and
I do believe that there are many,
many corporations in the world
that see the opportunity.
But, I'm glad that many of them
see the opportunity not just
to have a much larger consumer base.
But to do it right with
that consumer base so
that there's a long term benefit
as well as a short term profit.
>> Well, good.
So we're nearing the top of the hour.
I think this webinar potentially and
hopefully has left all of you on
the line with an appetite and
curiosity to learn more about this.
And to dive deeper into some of
the ways that we can actually affect
change as a result of all of
the complex challenges that we face as
a species really, and as a planet.
And I think there will be different
opportunities to do that.
So as Pamela mentioned,
there are two webinars that will be
coming up in May that will be led by
Professor Julia Novy-Hildesley as
well as Professor Banny Banerjee.
Both of these will be talking and
touching in more depth on some of these
topics that have been discussed today.
In addition, of course, we invite you to
join us in September to learn more about
this in person here on campus.
As a reminder the recording of this
webinar will be emailed to all of you
within a week.
So that you can review it again and
share with colleagues and friends.
And we will also be sending you some
additional information about other
opportunities to engage with us.
With that I want to wish you a very good
day and thank you for joining us today.